[Musik]
hallo zusammen ich habe mir gedacht ich
habe lange keine brownies mehr gegessen
und ich hatte richtig lust auf eine
braune torte die wir durch richtig
lecker und sie ist sehr einfach und die
braucht auch gar nicht viel equipment
dafür ich starte jetzt direkte mit einem
wasserbad ich schreibe euch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben wie immer hier
unten infobox dann könnt ihr euch das
nämlich einfach aufklappen screenshot
zum beispiel bei kaufland einkaufen
gehen und auf ganze dann nachmachen also
ein wasserbad ist folgendes wir brauchen
einfach einen topf mit kochend heißem
wasser dann brauchen wir ein bisschen
luft dazwischen und dann kommt ja
einfach eine feuerfeste also eine
hitzebeständige schüssel oben drüber und
da gehen jetzt drei zutaten rein einmal
mutter dann zucker moment aber und das
coole an diesem rezept ist dass ihr euch
praktisch ihre lieblingsschokolade
einfach hier rein geben könnte und die
schlemmer ja manchmal so eine süßigkeit
nachteile und dann habe ich letztens
eine edel bitterschokolade mit karamell
stückchen entdeckt und in dem ich heute
einfach die gebe ich jetzt mit dazu dann
wird das ganze einmal richtig schön
geschmolzen also wir lassen's schmelzen
und anschließend wieder ein bisschen
abkühlen ist nicht schlimm
[Musik]
so ich habe die schoko butter muss jetzt
noch mal zehn minuten abkühlen lassen
auf der arbeitsfläche weil wenn ihr
jetzt die eier rhein gibt und das ist
noch sehr heiß dann bekommt ihr direkt
früher also das stockt und dann schade
um die masse dann kann man sich noch
weiter verwenden die eier gebe ich jetzt
nach und nach dazu grüne sie ganz schön
um und anschließend komplett trockenen
zutaten mit dazu da habe ich jetzt nur
mehl und bei kakao in braunschweig kommt
nie backpulver rein weil wir wollen ja
das sehr schön facci bleibt und eben
nicht hochgeht
[Musik]
der braune basic ist jetzt quasi fertig
und das coole ist dass sie jetzt noch
entscheiden könnt ob wir dann müsste
drin haben möchtet ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel cranberries eingeben ich hab
noch walnüsse die hacke ich jetzt noch
grob und dann gebe ich sie in den teig
und den teig fertig sein direkt in einen
tortenring
[Musik]
so mein brownie war jetzt bei 170 grad
ober und unterhitze im vorgeheizten
backofen 5 ca 45 minuten das darf ruhig
45 minuten drin beim weil das ja auch
ein höherer brownie teig ist und ihm
merkt dass der bau nicht fertig und
nicht zu trocken ist wenn hierbei der
stäbchen probe einfach noch so ein
bisschen was an flüssigen teig hängen
bleibt bzw ist sich ganz flüssig aber
eher sofas und entgegen der regel wo ihr
andere teige da darf nichts hängen beim
sollte hier unbedingt aus hängen bleiben
so das gebe ich jetzt noch mal die seite
denn das muss einmal komplett auskühlen
aber ich zeige euch jetzt schon mal wie
wir das ganze toppen ich wollte nämlich
einerseits zwar frische sahne dazu aber
auch eine schokosoße und da gibt es ein
ganz einfachen trick wie ihr schokosoße
mit nur drei zutaten in nur einer minute
selber machen können ich habe hier
einfach bacau das ist der hier der
starke tötet dass es jetzt nicht mehr
trinke könnt ihr natürlich auch aus dem
ganzen backzutaten bonität mit drin dann
habe ich hier für die süße einfach etwas
puderzucker hat den einfachen grund dass
sich der puderzucker
besser gehts dann auflöst als
kristallzucker und da geben wir gleich
einfach sahne einrühren das
[Musik]
so die sache habe ich jetzt zusammen mit
vanille extrakt und ein bisschen sand
fest aufgeschlagen da braucht jetzt gar
keinen zusätzlichen zucker mehr und ich
starte mit dem zusammenstellen meiner
brownie torte dafür erstmal hier den
schönen hohen brownie aus den tortenring
entfernen dann gebe ich dir einfach hier
auf eine tortenplatte dann kommt die
sahne drüber und die schokosoße und
diesmal habe ich mir gedacht gibt es den
test auf der baustelle mit der clique
kurz zusammen im ruhrpark
[Musik]
also ich bin jetzt ja verbrauchsstelle
offen und ehrlich sein
die bereitstellung
ja sehr gut das hört sich gut an
wenn das nur etwa schmecken wir haben
eine kaltgetränke schulungen sind diese
richtig richtig lag der kreis getränke
geben und ansonsten sie morgens vermisst
[Musik]